[Music]
when you think of the most dominant
creature on earth
what comes to mind if considering
sheer size perhaps you immediately
thought of the ocean
and the largest animal that's ever lived
the blue whale
or perhaps thinking of strength and
ferocity you imagined lush forests full
of fearsome
big cats or maybe quite sensibly
you thought of us human beings the most
intelligent
and one of the most widespread animals
on the planet but if you were to walk
down the sidewalk or lean against a tree
the first animal that you would likely
encounter is something small
an ant their total population is around
10 000 trillion and when combined their
total weight would be about the same as
the weight of all human beings
in biomass and an impact on ecosystems
these small animals are arguably the
most successful creatures to have
ever lived ants have colonized almost
every land mass on earth
their presence is so significant that
they have directed the evolution of
countless other plant and animal species
aggressive warlike but also cooperative
and altruistic ants living in colonies
exhibit some of the most complex
behaviors of all
insects and the colony is the only thing
that matters in the lives of ants
their loyalty to it is absolute and in
their service to it
they exhibit some of the most complex
social behavior in the animal kingdom
giving rise to their nearly complete
ecological conquest of the earth
how do ant societies work and what is it
about the colony that has made ant so
successful
is it as simple as strength in numbers
or is it something more
profound
even though insects were among the first
animals to colonize land
cooperative insect societies are a
relatively recent development
the first insects emerged around 400
million years ago
but ants didn't emerge until much later
around 100 million years ago
they lived among the dinosaurs and for a
long time
did not rule the landscape this was the
era of the giant dragonflies
cockroaches and termites it wasn't until
60 million years ago that they became
the dominant insects
and since then they have truly
flourished
today there are around 16 000 different
species of ant
and they are found on every continent
except antarctica
the competitive edge that allowed ants
to become a world dominant group
is their highly developed colonial
existence and specialized social
structure
ant societies are broken up into two
castes
a non-reproductive worker cast and a
reproductive royal cast
the queen is the only reproducing female
of the entire colony
and the colony exists to serve her and
her alone
the birth of a colony begins with the
birth of a queen
the life of a queen begins when its
mother queen lays a special kind of egg
different from the millions of regular
worker eggs that the queen ant will lay
in her lifetime
these special eggs are laid when the
colony passes a certain size
and when they hatch they produce ants
that are larger than regular workers and
have wings
these are the reproductive males and
young queens
during what's called a nuptial flight
these winged ants take to the air and
mate with each other
after which the males die and the
females drop to the ground
scrape off their wings and begin to
search for a place to dig their nest
few get far in this journey predators
snag most of these young queens before
they can establish themselves
only around 1 in 500 new queens has a
chance at success
but those that do succeed become the
single egg-laying queen of their new
colony
over the course of her life a queen ant
can lay up to 300 million eggs
depending on the species of ant and the
vast majority of these
eggs hatch into dedicated worker ants
female ants whose lives are devoted to
the queen's welfare and reproductive
activity
at any given time there are millions of
worker ants maintaining the colony
there can be many different types and
many different sizes of workers
even within a single colony some care
for larvae
others excavate tunnels others build
amazing structures
while others leave the nest and search
for food or go to war with neighboring
colonies
and surprisingly it's the ant workers
themselves who
ultimately decide the fate of their
young choosing which worker cast they'll
develop
into larvae develop into different types
of workers based largely on the
nutrition they receive
those fed more insects than seeds are
more likely to become
larger individuals for leaf cutter ants
the polymorphism that exists among the
workers is extreme
the largest workers called soldiers
defend the colony
while the medium-sized workers collect
leaves excavate tunnels or collect
garbage and the smallest workers raise
the young and cultivate and farm fungus
the only food source for the whole
colony the workers
toil away in flawless synchrony in a
flow that looks chaotic to our eyes
but is in fact based on a complex system
of communication
a chemical and physical language
invisible to us
but binds these societies together
for years scientists knew that ants must
have some way to talk to each other in
order to organize their intricate
societies
but ants have poor vision and hearing so
scientists knew that ant communication
must work in a fundamentally different
way to ours
it was a mystery for years but in 1962
leading entomologist e.o wilson began to
crack the code of ant communication
he started with the question of how ants
tell other members of the colony the
location of a new food source
he noticed that ants often tap their
abdomen to the ground when traveling
so wondered if they were leaving some
sort of chemical trail
he began painstakingly dissecting fire
ant abdomens
crushing each of the organs with an
applicator stick he would then
spread the ant juice on a piece of paper
in front of other fire ants to see if
they would react
as he worked through each of the known
organs the ants showed no interest
but then he stumbled upon an organ that
had never been studied before
something called de four's gland when he
crushed this gland and spread it across
the paper
the ants went wild they followed the
trail
immediately and completely over time
scientists have discovered over 20
different pheromones that ants use to
communicate
and by combining different signals ants
have created a complex
pheromonal language african weaver ants
in particular
have the most sophisticated pheromone
communication system
ever studied in animals some of their
thoughts are expressed by spreading
pheromones on the ground
like previously mentioned combined with
physical gestures
when a worker wishes to say follow me i
found some food
she deposits a trail from the rectal
gland while running from the food back
to the nest
when she encounters other workers she
waves her head and touches the other ant
with her
two antennae or when a worker wishes to
raise the alarm about an enemy
she lays short looping trails around the
intruder with secretions from the
sternal gland
other signals are sent through the air
when an african weaver ant worker
encounters an enemy in her own territory
she releases a mixture of four chemicals
that not only convey a message
but elicit a response from all other
workers in her vicinity
the first tells the other ants to be
alert
the next one tells them to search for
the trouble the next one tells them to
come closer and bite anything in their
path
and the final compound tells them to go
nuts and attack
scientists believe that the combination
of these signals very closely resembles
syntax that we see in human language
a main reason ants are so successful in
the world then
is the same reason that we are like us
communication gives ants the amazing
capacity to cooperate
of all ants weaver ants are among the
most impressive
they dominate the forests in africa and
australia
in large part due to their complex and
efficient chemical communication
but perhaps more remarkable than their
ability to communicate so effectively
is what they can achieve with it weaver
ants are a species of ant that don't
live in or on the ground
but in the trees and to keep their huge
population safe there
they construct their own housing they
weave branches and leaves together to
create an
architectural feat full of a network of
different rooms complete with roofs
walls and floors
to begin the process a single ant
searches for a nice
bendy looking leaf it will pull on the
edges testing to see if the leaf will
curl
if the ant has some measure of success
other ants will be attracted to the
endeavor
and begin pulling on the edge as well as
the leaf bends more
more workers arrive they line up in
precise rows
gripping the edge pulling it towards
another leaf
if the gap is too large for a single row
of ants to seal
they perform an impressive acrobatic
tactic
they chain their bodies together to form
a living bridge
workers climb down the bodies of others
until the chain can reach the other leaf
edge
up to 10 workers long once the leaf
edges are within reach
the workers move into position to seal
the leaves together
but what looks like glue on the finished
structure is something even more
surprising
once the bent leaves are ready to be
sealed the workers will collect
larvae who are in the final stages of
development and use
their threads of silk to bind the leaves
together
holding the larvae in their mandibles
the workers move the larvae back and
forth across the leaf edges
using their babies like a hot glue gun
the larvae seem okay with this
and they respond to this motion by
exuding thousands of threads of silk
this silk becomes a sheet between the
edges and works as a powerful adhesive
structures like this speak to ant's
capacity to organize their labor
effectively
millions of individuals combining their
abilities into something much greater
it's easy to assume then that their
effectiveness comes down to a strength
in numbers
along with the communication to
orchestrate the work but this
can't account for all of their behavior
and all of their success
there's something more unifying in the
world of ants
and the individual ants cooperation with
one another is so profound
that it makes scientists rethink the
idea of individuality
the power of a group is evident with
more ants working together they can find
food more quickly
build more impressive structures and
defend against enemies more effectively
and working together is common in nature
birds in flocks or bison and herds live
longer when they live in groups
but in cooperative animal groups like
these individuals still look out for
their personal interests
for them it's not just about the group
but this
is not the case for ants worker ants die
young
and usually don't create offspring their
existence is sacrificial
they have no self-interest certain ants
have been found to suffer a death rate
of six percent per
hour when outside the nest due to
fighting with neighboring colonies
on average each forager survives for
only a week
but during that time she manages to
collect 20 times her own body weight in
food for the colony
all to support the group and ultimately
the queen
this unwavering loyalty to the queen and
the self-sacrifice to her cause
becomes more evident when a queen dies
logic would assume that when the queen
dies the workers would raise another
queen to replace her
but this is not at all what the workers
do in most cases the colony fails to
produce a royal successor
and it declines until the last worker
dies they simply do nothing until
there's no one left
this level of altruism and
self-sacrifice is so rare in the animal
kingdom
that it's made scientists rethink what
it means to be an individual
if ant individuals in a colony are not
competing against
each other if they are bound tightly by
communication
and a cast division of labor if they
can't survive
out of the colony for very long does the
concept of the individual
break down the idea of the superorganism
is one that has been debated for decades
with ants it's the idea that the colony
is the organism where the queen is the
reproductive organ
the workers the supporting brain heart
and gut
the exchange of food among the workers
is like the circulation of blood
the most advanced ant societies like
weaver ants driver ants or leaf cutter
ants
fall into this category where their
workers don't compete amongst themselves
at all
and do not reproduce outside of royalty
this capacity of the colony to act like
a single super organism has made
scientists reconsider evolutionary
theory as a whole
in the 1960s and 70s the conventional
way of thinking about evolution was
centered around
genes and genes alone largely
popularized by dawkins book the selfish
gene
it follows that the more two individuals
are genetically related
the more sense it makes for them to
behave selflessly with each other
that altruistic group behavior comes
down to each individual's competitive
desire to improve
chances of their kin's survival but some
ant biologists
like eo wilson believed that this
couldn't be the whole story
instincts from social species like ants
go far beyond the urge to protect their
immediate kin
the group must also have a role in
evolution
whether or not the group members are
related to each other and this idea gave
rise to the theory of multi-level
evolution
or group selection where natural
selection acts at the level of the group
instead of at the more conventional
level of the individual
the way ant societies function in their
daily lives
and within evolution has entranced us as
humans for decades
they have created heated debates among
the world's top scientists
and been the focus of every kid's
backyard curiosity
their world operates in ways our brains
can barely conceive
with chemical signals painted on the
ground instincts that drive them to
fatal endeavors
and yet their sociality cooperation
and complexity in many ways mirrors our
own
studying ants will continue to reveal
answers about the nature of evolution
and in turn will reveal answers about
our own society
and our own individuality
studying the animal kingdom gives
insight into our world
and brings researchers on all sorts of
journeys
both intellectual and physical some of
the research about ants happens in the
field
in the steamy tropics or the frigid
parts of northern finland
and some of it's done in the lab with
complex apparatuses engineered to study
ants chemical trails or their
inclination to go to war with each other
hearing about what it takes to carry out
research like this
is often just as interesting as the
science itself
i love hearing the human stories behind
the science
and this is why we decided to start a
podcast
modulus hosted by me and brian from real
engineering
is a podcast about the people behind the
science we explore here on youtube
we talk to the scientists who are on the
cutting edge of research
and the people who are affected by the
topics we discuss
the second episode of modulus is out now
it's an episode where i talk to two
pioneers of the ocean
some of the world's first saturation
divers they discuss what it's like to
live at the bottom of the ocean
and how it affects both your body and
your mind
this episode is available now on nebula
the streaming platform made by me
and several other educational youtube
content creators
it's the place to watch and listen to
our videos and podcasts
ad free along with original content
that's not available anywhere else
like real engineering the logistics of
d-day or
sam from wendover's new trivia show
which features creators like brian
competing in sometimes silly tasks
and trying not to make fools out of
themselves we can take more risks and
have more fun on nebula
where we don't have to worry about the
youtube algorithm there's so much
original content there with more being
added all the time
and to make it even better nebula has
partnered with curiosity stream
the streaming platform with thousands of
high budget high quality documentaries
there are loads of the best nature films
like david attenborough's ant mountain
which explores one of the largest animal
societies in the world
a super colony of ants with more than a
billion members
nestled within the swiss alps it dives
into
a whole new area of ant biology that i
never knew
and since it's a david attenborough film
you know it's going to be good
and for a limited time curiosity stream
is still offering 26
off their annual plans making a yearly
subscription just 14.79
so by signing up at curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula
for just 14.79 for the entire year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and
all of your favorite educational content
creators thanks for watching and if
you'd like to see more from me
the links to my instagram twitter and
patreon are below
you